all right y'all we're back and i'm here
with my friend give it up
um so treat trisha three shows i'm gonna
say your name forever
likes to keep it real just like me um
and so it's time to find out what she
really would
and wouldn't do and
i want the truth in certain situations
with a quick round of
treasure year would or wouldn't
okay so i'm gonna hit this button and an
awkward scenario
will appear on the screen trisha and i
will have to say what we would or
wouldn't do
in each case are you ready i'm so ready
okay here we go
okay okay
so you bring your dog to a friend's
house and you find your dog by the shoes
at the entrance
he's pooped in your friend's shoe you
clean the poop
but would you or wouldn't you tell your
friend
who doesn't tell your friend that your
dog
i mean you have to say like
plus i'm i'm pretty sure like if i
cleaned your shoe
you're still gonna know it's gonna be
wet
why does my shoe smell like poop like
you're gonna know i would tell i would
tell you i would tell i'll be like so
there was this time that you invited me
over
and then my dog took a poo in your shoe
so sorry about that yeah we're good
friends
okay your best friend forever needs you
to move a body
no questions asked would you or wouldn't
you help
i'm going to help you find a really nice
attorney
yeah i ain't going down for i don't i
don't believe that i would we're the
same
we're trying to not you know that my
sister called i love you elisabeth
but i would visit you every day in
prison i mean my question really should
be would you
help move a body again but let's just
move on to the next question
would you do it again it was risky the
first time
i'll never do that again
okay here's another okay okay
you have your boss and her family over
for dinner your new puppy
wanders in with a toy and a toy
toy would you or wouldn't you admit
what the toy was 100 i'd be all in oh no
i would just make up something
like ridiculous oh my god oh this is
this really special massager that i just
got that i was told to be really good
for my shoulder that's
giving me trouble i know it's bright
purple but
let's spin again
you're in your office and you think it's
safe so you let it
rip just just then
your co-worker walks in would you or
wouldn't you be honest about the smell
i'd totally own it i'd probably totally
own it yeah
i'd be like my bad
sorry i don't know if i don't know i
might lie about it it just depends i
might just pretend it didn't happen
people do that to
to you though people do it's like you
know and then they're like
what you're like like just say you did
that
like come on i love my kids my kids are
i'm like was that you
yep like it's like ownership they're
proud of them like i need to calm this
down you're gonna get made fun of
i can't smell right now so it's like see
you can't smell you're the greatest
friend to have right
here except for i also don't know if i
do something
i'm brushing my teeth a lot i'm like i
don't know what smells like ideas
[Laughter]
this is so good so fun we need a
therapist
i have one your last french fry falls
between the seat in your car
would you or wouldn't you go fish for it
and eat it yes 100
here's the thing i wouldn't go for a
french fry it's weird i know i'm texting
i'm southern i'm not like a huge french
fry person
but if that was chocolate i would call
to get to it mean how would you guys
have bought a burger and fries and the
fries fall over in the car on the way
home into the floorboard
you're gonna get those fries that's
happening yeah once again not with that
but like with other food yeah
involving chocolate yeah so we're we're
the same
yeah yeah i would do it for a french fry
and that was treasure you would or
wouldn't
everybody you're welcome um so it's
always lovely to see you it's great
i love you i'm six feet away i know
you're you still
you probably smoke i can't smell you you
can't smell me
so look i'm stubbed look for the trisha
yearwood pet collection everybody online
and in stores right now
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever help